hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video is going to be a bit of a
doozy but it was so heavily requested
so we're gonna be reviewing caroline
daisler's 10 day body reset program but
first let me tell you about my sponsor
luna so all of my regular followers know
that i struggle big time with sleep i
just find that after a really hectic
stressful day of fighting pseudoscience
and also like being a mom it is hard to
turn my brain off at night and i've done
all the recommended exercises but it's
almost like the harder i try to sleep
the harder it is to sleep i mean leave
me a comment below if you can relate so
i was really excited when my friend told
me about luna so the luna app is an
amazing tool with a wide range of
relaxation and sleep supports they have
these charming romantic stories that you
can listen to with a really calm and
chill narrator they've got some
beautiful visuals of different colors
and textures like their japanese garden
or luminescent tree and they have
soundscapes that allow you to put your
phone away and just focus on the sound
but luna is different from other
relaxation apps in that it fully
immerses you it uses proven techniques
for relaxation like an art activity
guided storytelling ambient sounds and
music that can evoke the state of
relaxation before sleep so if you want
to give luna a try and help get yourself
in the right mood for sleep and
relaxation check out the link in my
description or scan the qr code you're
seeing right now to get a seven day
trial today now of course a quick
reminder to check out my disclaimer
including a trigger warning as we will
be discussing calories and other
problematic eating behaviors so feel
free to skip this video if it's not
supportive to your journey also a
reminder to subscribe to this channel
and ring that little bell so that you
never miss out on an episode all right
first of all
caroline remember her so i reviewed this
nutritionist
two years ago and i'm still feeling kind
of triggered by it but you guys asked me
so many times to revisit and discuss
caroline's raw vegan diet and
specifically asked me to take a look at
her brand new 10 day body reset program
so let's get into it because there's a
lot to unpack so i paid for this and
downloaded it and the book begins with
the much needed disclaimer all the
information provided in this plan is for
educational and inspirational purposes
only please seek help from a
professional if you have any concerns or
personal struggles that need to be
addressed all right so
i guess we're done here right well i
wish that were so now i know you're
probably all asking yourself what the
[ __ ] is a reset anyway i don't really
know caroline please tell me but reset
seems to be just another pseudoscience
wellness word synonymous with detox in
other words it's something that you
absolutely do not need to do now the
alleged benefits of set reset include
clear skin weight loss better sleep
increased energy better digestion
improved physical health increased brain
function improved emotional health
longevity and vitality obviously we have
no evidence that the plan will result in
any of these things because when you're
not regulated by a governing body
designed to protect the public you can
say that your product will do whatever
the hell you want it to without
consequence or any data to back it up
but anyways let's take a look at what
you have to do
in order to reap these alleged benefits
in said plan
first of all the good so caroline isn't
into calorie counting and suggests that
this lifestyle means we can eat in
abundance and never restrict she also
says that her own personal serving sizes
may not work for everyone and that you
should eat the amount that you feel will
satisfy you
great but then on the same page we get
the list of what we will be restricting
cool that song it's not fun and i didn't
feel it is a fun song and i didn't feel
basically the plan gets you 10 days
worth of vegan recipes that contain no
refined sugar processed oils animal
products or gluten why are we instructed
to limit all these things for 10 days i
actually do not know
carolyn doesn't actually say yes sugar
and oils are sources of added calories
and i know caroline is vegan so there
are ethical considerations there but
gluten unless you are celiac or have
gluten intolerance there is no reason to
be swearing off gluten from your diet in
fact if weight loss is your goal a lot
of gluten-free alternatives are actually
higher in calories and lower in
satiating fiber than their gluten-filled
counterparts the most likely outcome
from cutting these foods out for 10
random days of your life is that it's
going to trigger you to over consume
them when you get to day 11. but anyways
there are actually two options in this
plan one for weight loss and one for
weight maintenance
both are packed with tons of
restrictions and inadequacies with the
only real difference being what you can
have for lunch in the case of the weight
loss option caroline references this
calorie density chart honestly i should
be more shocked that caroline claims
that her plan is all about abundance and
not restriction when it's rooted in this
outdated diet rhetoric and i hate
everything
but honestly
nothing contradictory that a wellness
influencer says or does
really surprises me anymore so these
charts based on weight are horribly
misleading and completely strip foods of
their nutrient value and satiety factor
so for example we know that foods like
avocado and nuts are more calorie dense
by weight when compared to non-starchy
vegetables but they also offer more
protein and or fat which makes them more
satiating because well
you guys know
the hunger crushing combo also what's
this girl got against popcorn i'm not
saying that popcorn's a super food but
if we're using caroline's faulty logic
on what constitutes a health food
popcorn is super high fiber low calorie
and it's a great snack and if we're
talking about weight a pound of popped
popcorn equals 50 cups
if you eat 50 cups of popcorn you're
probably gonna be pretty damn full but
if you eat a generous more normal like
five cup serving of popcorn you're
getting a snack with less than 200
calories and six grams of saturating
fiber i don't know sounds like a pretty
awesome choice for weight loss to me but
anyways that is not the only bit of
faulty logic on this plan so as an
example caroline suggests starting each
day with lighter sweeter meals and then
transitioning to heavier more savory
foods at night to promote optimal
digestion and prevent sugar cravings at
night
um
not really there's no evidence to
suggest that consuming sweeter foods
earlier in the day helps with digestion
or to reduce sugar cravings
the actual best way to prevent sugar
cravings at night is to make sure that
you're eating enough in the day and also
that you're eating foods that you
inherently enjoy
and if meal size and timing does have
any measurable effect on weight at all
research actually suggests that front
loading your calories in the morning and
consuming smaller meals at night
may be better associated with better
insulin sensitivity blood pressure and
appetite control this is also why
caroline's recommendation in support of
intermittent fasting with an eating
window of 12 pm and 8 pm
is also maybe not the best universal
advice now i've spoken ad nauseum about
intermittent fasting in my video right
here
but in short the evidence suggests it's
no more effective at promoting weight
loss compared to continuous caloric
restriction
it's just another rule that reduces the
likelihood of you eating enough calories
period since the data suggests that
we're just kind of bad at making up for
lost meals most of the time anyway it's
also not uncommon for people to actually
gain weight during intermittent fasting
since they can let themselves get so
ravenous they overeat when they get to
their eating window so i would say like
most things it's really kind of
different strokes for different folks
now if this doesn't sound like torture
enough for 10 days
what's potentially even more problematic
is the insinuation that this is more of
a
lifestyle thing
yeah caroline actually suggests that
this plan is something that works long
term and is sustainable
uh no caroline no god please no no
cutting out all oils sugar gluten animal
products and shunning healthy nutritious
foods like nuts seeds and whole grains
due to their caloric content
is not a lifestyle it's an eating
disorder to suggest that anyone should
be taking on this diet short term is
problematic and misinformed to suggest
that anyone be taking on this diet long
term
is dangerous
so let's talk about what you are
actually going to eat
so since caroline is mostly raw vegan
she suggests getting most of your
protein from foods like nori avocado and
mushrooms
so let's try that shall we now just to
get 75 grams of protein in your day
which is actually a very modest amount
for most women you would be looking at
about 18 avocados 240 white mushrooms or
80 sheets of nori seaweed i don't know
about you but
i'd rather not
it also seems very confusing and also
inefficient that she's recommending such
calorically dense foods like avocado as
your protein source
when she just called out avocados as a
food to avoid in that stupid chart there
are other plant-based proteins that are
much more efficient sources like tofu
beans and lentils and while caroline has
shunned tofu products for being too
processed she doesn't explain why beans
and legumes are avoided on the reset
probably because
this diet just makes no actual sense now
for fat intake caroline recommends
getting fats from whole foods like
avocados nuts and seeds rather than from
oils since according to her you get the
benefit of the fiber intact and that's
true well i don't think we need to avoid
oil altogether i also don't think it's
bad advice to get the majority of your
fats from whole food sources that come
equipped with better satiety factors and
volume especially if weight loss is your
goal but just to poke some holes in her
reasoning here caroline does juice all
of her fruits and vegetables in the
morning which also strips them of those
beneficial fibers it's also pretty
confusing that the very same fat sources
she recommends are also on the avoid
list for weight loss i mean
there's a lot of mixed messages going on
and i'm confused and if i'm confused i
can imagine how
most of her followers feel as for carbs
well there's no huge shortage of that
the majority of the calories on this
diet are going to be coming from very
large amounts of fruit and potatoes most
of which are served up in mono meals of
just one food
so on day one for the weight loss option
for example she suggests consuming over
three to four times the amount of
carbohydrates that most people need just
to maintain their weight
never mind to create a caloric deficit
and most of those calories are served
without any fat or protein to help
promote satiety and stabilize blood
sugars
honestly it's so bad it hurts my soul
but
let's support each other here and dive a
little bit deeper into caroline's
specific meal recommendations on the
plan so starting with the classic
wellness culture tropes we start our day
with one to one and a half liters of
lemon detox water and two cups of celery
juice
where do we even
start well first of all caroline insists
that you need to consume all juices and
smoothies on an empty stomach first to
help improve their nutrient absorption
nope this is food combining bs having
fat or protein in your stomach when you
consume fruits and vegetables will not
cause any kind of digestion or
absorption traffic jam in your gut our
body is
well equipped to send out the right
cocktail of enzymes to help your body
break down whatever is on board also if
we want to get really nitpicky
having some fat in there may actually
improve the absorption of nutrients in
something like celery juice since its
vitamin a and k
are fat soluble and are therefore better
absorbed with a little bit of fat
also i know i've discussed this in
previous videos but there are no
benefits of celery juice beyond just
getting in some extra fluids and a few
micronutrients
it's not detoxing it doesn't inherently
clear up your skin improve mood or boost
energy and if it does lead to weight
loss it's because it's only got like 40
calories per cup celery is also rich in
fodmaps which when consumed in excess
can cause
well
the runs
[Music]
what are you doing it's coming out of me
like lava so
yeah
i guess if diarrhea is caroline's
definition of a good morning detox or if
it's her top weight loss hack then
yeah i guess this makes some sense
it's also worth flagging that caroline
breaks her own rule with the celery
juice which she suggests she drinks as
early as 10 a.m news flash folks celery
juice like all foods or drinks with
calories will break a fast and yes i
realize that that's almost a moot point
because as i said before
the main benefits of fasting for weight
loss is not the reduction in insulin
release but rather just basically
reduced calorie consumption and like i
said celery juice is very very low in
calories so many big holes in these
suggestions i don't know how this boat
is not gonna sink
anyway
aside from all the low calorie fluids
the first meal of caroline's day is the
post workout green smoothie so her
smoothie recipes change slightly day to
day but they generally follow the same
format of having mostly greens some
fruit and water so day one for example
is a handful of celery stalks one bunch
of parsley two large swiss chard leaves
a frozen banana a handful of frozen or
fresh pineapple and one cup of water
sounds
um
nutrition
now while i appreciate the solid variety
of fruit and veggies in here
i would love to see some fats in protein
to really bump up the satiety factor and
like i said improve the absorption of
those fat soluble vitamins so maybe some
nut butter protein powder silken tofu or
a higher protein plant-based milk like
pea or soy which i know yes i know these
are suggestions that defy her bs rules
interestingly
caroline actually explicitly says that
her smoothie isn't intended for it to
keep her full
she actually wants to digest it quickly
so then she can just get on with her
lunch i mean i've never understood this
concept like if weight loss is your goal
why would it seem like a good idea to
drink almost 200 calories that will not
even contribute to satiety
anyways i digress moving on lunch
usually consists of the infamous mono
meal
aka just a ton of fruit so on day one
for example she recommends 13 pounds of
watermelon 13 freaking pounds
that is probably not gonna feel so good
at least it wouldn't for me
watermelon is considered high fodmap and
consuming it in excess can cause a lot
of bloating diarrhea and other digestive
issues in folks with sensitive guts so
yeah i wouldn't be
loving that meal now on day eight
caroline switches it up a bit and
suggests that you can have a large plate
of watermelon followed by 20 figs or 10
dates because apparently
this order of consumption helps to
reduce the bloat again it's now quite
clear to me that we can add food
combining to the list of pseudoscience
wellness gimmicks that caroline
subscribes to again there is no evidence
that eating food in a particular order
will improve digestion or reduce
bloating like your body doesn't know or
care if you eat your watermelon or your
figs first but you know what actually
helps to reduce bloating um
not eating huge amounts of high fodmap
fruit anyways caroline claims that the
reason she likes watermelon is because
of its alkalinizing properties so yeah
we're really going through that wellness
culture bs bingo card today
folks
foods cannot i repeat
cannot change the ph of your blood and
therefore their acidic or alkaline
characteristics mean nothing at all our
body actually has a very sophisticated
buffer system to manage variations in
the ph of foods and if it didn't
she wouldn't be doing so well after her
one and a half liters of lemon water
this is not going so great moving on to
dinner we are largely looking at salads
or salad ingredients wrapped in like a
sheet of nori under the faulty pretense
of being a rat all of these dinners also
contain some kind of oil-free salad
dressing made up of pureed vegetables
herbs seeds and vinegar she also
sometimes incorporates a side of
potatoes or sweet potatoes with her
dinner but says that you should eat your
salad first and then the potatoes for
optimal digestion again there's no
scientific reason for this it is not
surprisingly just more of that food
combining bs now when i checked out
caroline's instagram for her personal
wedding days i found them to be pretty
much exactly what is presented here
lemon water celery juice a crap ton of
fruit salad and potatoes so carbs on
carbs on carbs with a load of water and
a crap ton of fiber so
at least she practices what she preaches
anyway this all sounds like total
torture to me and i probably wouldn't be
able to leave the house on a plane like
this out of fear of
my pants but if you were feeling ballsy
or just like really lonely and you
wanted to go out for dinner
your options would be
pretty sad for instance when eating at
an italian restaurant caroline suggests
ordering a plain green salad with mashed
avocado as the dressing and then having
plain tomato pasta with no cheese
sounds like a great time to meet but if
you do the safe thing and eat all of
your meals at home you might actually
need an industrial sized kitchen
just to accommodate your next walmart
haul caroline's menu includes over 30
large bulky produce items that require
refrigeration including 15 heads of
celery and 14 heads of lettuce
and this is for just one person
if your partner or kids want to eat
something other than like canned tuna
out of the pantry
i'm sorry but
they are apparently
out of luck the shopping list also
includes 25 lemons two watermelons two
honey melons and six honeydew melons
ringing in at about 500
for the 10 days considering how
unsatisfied you're likely to feel on
this diet that is actually insane
and on that note let's take a look at
the stats so when i analyzed a few of
the 10 days on the weight loss stream i
found that on average you're looking at
around 2 500 calories but sometimes as
many as 4 000 calories with up to 82
percent of calories from carbs and the
rest from protein and fat
so on a lot of those days we're looking
at a pretty skewed macronutrient split
basically the plan is veg and fruit
heavy and rich in fiber water and volume
which generally may help folks looking
to lose weight but ultimately it does
come down to calories and i would bet
that most women who struggle with their
weight
wouldn't lose a lot of weight if they
ate four thousand calories of straight
up carbs there's also an exorbitant
amount of fiber here
now considering that most north
americans don't even meet the 25 to 37
gram recommendation
consuming four to five times that amount
in high fodmap foods
is surely going to wreak havoc on most
people's guts now honestly there is so
much wrong here i don't even know where
to start with the recommendations
but i think we just gotta like
start fresh no mono meals no to food
combining
no to celery juice and alkaline diets no
no no
for a diet averaging 2500 calories which
is a normal healthy amount of calories
to consume for a lot of people we need
to see more protein and fat to help
promote satiety without the digestive
stress and without needing to be eating
like all day long my jaw is hurting just
thinking about chewing all of that fruit
now i just want to close with a brief
discussion on some of the major
problematic themes here because if you
didn't have a shaky relationship with
food before you bought this reset plan
you absolutely will after first of all
the fact that caroline claims that this
diet isn't restrictive is an actual
trolling joke you're restricted from
animal-based products refined sugar oil
and gluten
and you're limited to very small amounts
of whole grains beans legumes soy and
even whole foods sources of fat like
nuts and seeds
you're also restricted to when you can
eat via intermittent fasting and also
the order that you're supposed to eat
foods in like could you make eating any
more complicated if someone were to lose
weight on a diet like this it would
probably be because they were so
stressed and overwhelmed with all of the
rules they might just say
it's too much of a hassle to even have a
meal now i also looked at a bunch of
caroline's instagram posts and found
them to be riddled with diet culture and
pseudoscience
from demonizing sugar to suggesting
monomials to deep bloat to sharing
recipes for a flat tummy etc
this account is toxic hard stop
so in conclusion caroline's ebook is so
confusing and misinformed i am not even
sure how it makes sense in her head if
you do this for 10 days you will likely
be very hungry unsatisfied and actually
probably very bloated and if you do this
for longer you will be likely
malnourished if you lose weight it will
be from water or from sheer unhappiness
and boredom from all of the mono meals
and crazy rules and if you don't lose
weight it's because you're eating
massive portions of fruit in either
scenario your relationship with food is
sure to suffer so i just really don't
see what the possible benefit could be
i'm sorry but there are better ways to
spend your hard-earned cash than this
body reset so for so many reasons i give
this a huge pass and on that note that
is all that i have for you guys today if
you like this video be sure to give it
the thumbs up leave me a comment below
on who you'd like to see me review next
subscribe to the channel and i will see
you next time on abby's kitchen bye
and for more great videos like this
check out the link right here
you